the year is coming to an end which means
two things the game awards and an
onslaught of trailers and a bunch of
game releases to hit christmas sales
although strangely there aren't that
many december releases
but let's talk about what there is
finally after years of waiting a
franchise that stood out since its first
release is finally coming back on a
brand new console frankly is a dream
come true so
here it is with its last main game
releasing back in 2017
we're finally seeing a return
of danganronpa
[Music]
that's right danganronpa is seeing a
release on the nintendo switch on
december 3rd with danganronpa decadence
decadence includes the first second and
third games all playable as a collection
for the portable system and i am
especially excited about it as i still
haven't had a chance to play danganronpa
v3 killing harmony so i am ready to jump
back into this twist and murder mystery
for those of you who haven't played the
dong on rompa series these games put
your high school aged anime characters
into a death game and while death game
plots have been fairly common in
japanese media for a while and become
specifically relevant lately in the
states thanks to korea's squid game the
very specific twist of danganronpa's
death game is that its students are
trapped together and the only way to get
out is by murdering another student
after murder a trial takes place if the
wrong person is accused of being the
murderer then the true killer gets to
leave and everybody else dies
however if the murderer is correctly
identified they're killed and the rest
of the students are still trapped in the
same vicious game
the gameplay itself is kind of like
phoenix wright ace attorney in that you
have a chance to explore and investigate
before murders take place
then once a murder takes place you'll
have to spot lies and contradictions in
order to correctly spot the killer the
story itself has fun and intriguing
twists as it does have an overall
mystery to it and it's definitely worth
checking out if you don't mind games
with a heavy focus on graphic novel
elements
[Music]
sorry about that i was just uh murder i
mean i mean getting ready to talk about
halo
don gone rumpa decadence releases
december 3rd
okay
okay i admit it last time i was bad and
teased you guys with the whole halo
infinite tease thing
but i'm over that it's time for the 2021
game that you've all been waiting for
it's built on an established game that
is known around the world
cricket 22
that's right the sport known all around
the world
as a sport that's only played in the uk
is here
you see the thing is youtube doesn't
have a functioning dislike button
anymore so why even try
also if you're into cricket that's cool
i actually do hope it's a good game
okay
okay no more jokes i know what you all
want to hear i know what you all clicked
on this video for even though you
already know it's coming out and that's
disney magical world 2 my happy life
enchanted edition i just bought tickets
for my fiance and i to go to disneyland
for one day it was 350
350
good thing i could have spent 50 dollars
instead on this nintendo switch port of
a nintendo ds game dreams do come true
it has been six years since halo 5 and
even longer since a halo game that was
as universally adored as halo 3. but
halo infinite by all accounts seems to
be the game that we have all been
waiting for
343 industries has been working to make
halo infinite the master chief
experience fans have been clamoring for
on every front the multiplayer with the
beta back in august 2021 was first
created as a unique to halo experience
and has been tweaked with feedback from
fans instead of copying trends like call
of duty or battle royales this
multiplayer experience has focused on
the various modes that made halo the
multiplayer king that it was but equally
important to the games is the campaign
and on this front halo infinite looks to
be a strong return to the story
characters and a world we've fallen in
love with over the years joseph staton
who is the director of cinematics for
halo 1 2 and 3 at bungie was brought on
as head of creative for halo infinite if
you missed it make sure to check out
some more hussein's glowing preview of
halo infinite or phil's tips on how to
be a better spartan in halo infinite's
multiplayer we'll be sure to have plenty
of other halo infinite content for you
here at gamespot also i'm contractually
obligated to say make sure to t bag that
subscribe button for more halo infinite
content halo infinite releases december
8th
five nights at freddy's is back with the
first game in quite some time for the
series while the game saw regular
releases after its first release in 2014
this is the longest wait we've ever had
and security breach will be different in
a number of key ways for one rather than
a pizzeria the game takes place in a
mall for two and most notably the game
no longer takes place in one stationary
room but actually allows free roaming
there will also be combat and boss
battles the hotly anticipated five
nights at freddy's security breach
releases december 16th
originally supposed to release in
november the final fantasy xiv expansion
and walker was bumped to this december
but you don't have to wait long final
fantasy xiv and walker now officially
releases on december 7th with early
access available as early as december
3rd
those are probably the biggest releases
but i'd like to take a moment to talk
about a bunch of indie games i
personally think look cool coming out in
december
happy's humble burger farm is the sequel
to the name your own price horror game
happy's humble burger barn the original
game saw you as an employee of a fast
food chain where weirder and weirder
things slowly happen it'll be cool to
see where scythe dev team takes the
sequel happy's humble burger farm
releases december 3rd
white shadows looks to be a puzzle
platform game and a similar style to
play dead's limbo or inside the
dystopian world and art style of the
game look particularly interesting to me
and i'm personally a fan of these types
of games white shadows releases december
7th
remember when car combat was a thing
while keo looks to be a revival of this
genre and as a fan of the long dormant
twisted metal and vigilante 8 games i am
all for it keo releases for early access
on december 9th
fire girl hack and splash looks like a
charming take on the 2d hack and slash
genre here instead of villains you'll be
fighting against pyro monsters and
chopping down obstacles in your way as
you attempt to rescue civilians fire
girl hack and splash releases december
14th
rogue invader has been in the works
since at least 2015.
this game is a roguelite action shooter
where you'll be able to customize your
weapons and collect loot to either help
you with your current run or future runs
if you like roguelikes it seems to be an
interesting take on the genre rogue
invader releases december 15th
trash sailors looks like a fun couch
co-op style game where you'll have to
work together to gather trash in order
to both fix and feel your raft steer
around obstacles and defeat enemies
trash sailors releases to pc december
16th
created by image and form creators of
the steamworld series with steamworld
dig 2 being particularly excellent in my
opinion the gunk is an upcoming
action-adventure game where you're
tasked with vacuuming up and cleaning
gunk from an otherwise beautiful planet
image and form have a history of making
good titles so hopefully this will
follow suit the gunk releases december
16th
so there you have the biggest games
coming out this december what are you
the most excited for and why is it
disney magical world too
let me know in the comments and i'll see
you guys next time peace
[Music]
you